the first shot of the modern vaccine in
the united states could be given as soon
as this morning
trucks carrying the first delivery left
the distribution center in olive branch
mississippi yesterday
the pfizer vaccine is in its second week
of distribution
mola lange is at a long island jewish
medical center in queens new york one of
the many hospitals
giving out the pfizer vaccine mola you
have new guidance on which groups
should be vaccinated next what can you
tell us
oh good morning vlad yeah an expert
panel advising the cdc voted yesterday
that the next round of vaccinations
should go
to people 75 years and older as well as
essential
frontline workers people like teachers
first responders
grocery store employees this as uh
people continue to get vaccinated here
at this hospital in queens as they are
around the country uh
nurses doctors continuing to get their
shots this as the second authorized
vaccine
that moderna vaccine now comes into play
i was very honored to be asked
ups driver todd elbel's 78-year-old
father
died from the coronavirus in november on
sunday the ups veteran was behind the
wheel of a truck in kentucky carrying
some of the first
doses of the moderna vaccine this has
been my
most important load that i've hauled i
feel dad was in the truck with me today
the cdc says more than half a million
americans received the first doses of
the pfizer biontech vaccine
modernis vaccine is said to be around 94
percent effective and pfizer's 95
percent
both require two doses modernist 28 days
after the first
and pfizer 21 days but a key difference
modernism does not need to be stored in
extremely cold temperatures
making it easier to distribute we will
be shipping
five 5.9 million doses of the modern
vaccine and 2 million doses of the
pfizer vaccine
on monday operation warp speed the
federal government's vaccine program
says it's on track to have 20 million
vaccines available by the end of this
month
which is about half of its previous
estimates at least a dozen states also
say
they are receiving fewer doses than
expected the number of doses available
to us to allocate
ended up being lower over the weekend
general gus
perna the logistics head of operation
warp speed took the blame
so to the governors to the governor's
staffs
please accept my personal apology if
this was disruptive
ed bill says he is looking forward to
getting his vaccine
whenever that may be i'm going to take
the vaccine myself i'm going to be first
in line for my father
i'll tell you that much i feel in my
heart that everybody should to help get
this stopped
well the cdc says that six people have
had an allergic reaction to that pfizer
vaccine one of those people
did have a history of allergic reactions
all six cases were treated
cbc says uh also that uh 100 million
people are on track
to be vaccinated throughout the country
jamie by this february
great moa thank you